yeah yeah you guys sip the drinks and
you guys are dancing [ __ ] what it do
s ng 3 4 3 4 well I'm freeze yeah 34
weeks breath date before we
consecutively
back-to-back-to-back-to-back mad great
feet
oh this is something that it's close to
having for you we haven't spoke about it
but you were going off on it
Harvey Weinstein oh god yeah
he's pretty dead by the time this comes
out he's got coronavirus in it as he
vies got it in pen oh and he's unlike
life I think he's on life support and
stuff oh sure yeah so yeah I feel bad
even though his own monster what I feel
bad if I'm gunning him if he's dead
by the time this comes out with [ __ ]
okay so obviously he's done in it I'll
use duh
otherwise he's dead he's dead he's dead
it's not even jokes he's dirt he's a
white Bill Cosby nothing he is he's yeah
he is it you the white Bill Cosby Bill
copy the worst oh yeah he's a drag in
people
Bill Cosby was worse but um yeah our you
want Harvey wants is a different thing
yeah the reason I like he interests me
so much is that who's got that kind of
bollocks who's got that kind of bollocks
to be let brough if you want to be in
this movie suck me off
suck me the [ __ ] off and I'll get you in
this movie who has that kind of goal I
would never have the balls to it never
have the boss even both of those words
broke because you know man like you know
obviously you've been in situations in
your life where you're in your your
you're in a scenario yeah we've a girl
yeah and all these million different
situations go for your head like yeah
I'd love if this happened and I love if
I just said this and then she did this
or I love if we just initiate this or if
I love it had the ball so just black
brav
that's fun let's do something like
anything yeah but that's movie chap
that's not real chap the reality is both
of us finish this plutonic conversation
we go we go off yeah nothing never
happens but Harvey Weinstein was like
now this does happen from these Monday
interviewing they want to be in this
movie and I'm telling base you want to
be in the movie come that's sucking [ __ ]
let's get crazy that's bollocks man
that's bravado yes is I think the first
time he must have done it he must have
been shamed
he must have been [ __ ] he must be
because no one has the confidence just
to say that you don't yeah I don't care
who you are you're the boss to be like
what we doing here let's go or maybe
when the first time he experienced
something like that was maybe she was
coming on to him yeah maybe maybe she
was I'll do anything anything anything
and he was like what do you mean like
what he's probably like a young buck and
you know ties up tight so what do you
mean anything like and she just looks so
much anything found grabs his dick asset
anything my whole be Amish
my heart will be out of my chest I
wouldn't know what to do I wouldn't know
what to do I would know what to dad is
whether I do or not
mmm I'd know what to do oh I definitely
know what today bro was well known on
the disgrace will turn on no one could
do nothing him so maybe that could have
potentially been the initial scenario
that turned him into a [ __ ] rapist no
now look at him in jail wrong that's the
thing like I say it all the time
mmm nobody thinks they're about person
hmm so it must have got to a point well
once he got escalated to the point where
he was actually foot on raping [ __ ]
he must have been like oh they want it
oh for sure on it for sure no one I've
been [ __ ] heroes for years they all
want it wait say the sentence again the
green to the wrong thing say the set is
all again when it by the time let's just
say yeah in fair round
that's an hour we just said yeah yeah
this is what happened the first time
yeah and maybe even the second time yeah
maybe even the third time yeah and then
he started he started to fill in the
gaps yeah so he's letting more initiate
then he starts initiate and then he was
hardly initiating it was still he was
still [ __ ] hmm once it gone from
there
fast forward however many years it was
14 15 years and now he's full-on raping
[ __ ] now mmm
he must still be thinking in his head
like this is what they want because
they'll do anything for this movie this
must be what they want because I've been
[ __ ] [ __ ] for years and I never
even used to try mmm so I'm assuming he
never fought like oh I love raping hoes
you know I mean yeah I doubt he was
thinking like I love being a rapist okay
he's probably thinking like this is just
like a one yeah this is the game like
they want me mmm I'm a big powerful guy
I've been [ __ ] so many of these
actresses yes so many years yeah they're
here for it yeah and obviously she wants
to she's bought it he's probably
thinking for us she just wants to save
face
yeah actually say no but she don't mean
nice mmm like obviously they all say yes
they all say yes that's we'll come back
to that that's a slippery slope come
back to that when they say no she really
museum we'll come back to that
well that doesn't appear in my life no
means no oh good no means no don't get
me wrong don't get twisted let's say be
our context do you [ __ ] editing cons
no means no so scenario okay you're
you're [ __ ] with a girl right no not
actually [ __ ] but you mean girl yeah
guys I'm gone you guys are flying back
and forth back and forth yeah yeah yeah
let me put my hair itself in the picture
going back and forth back and forth yeah
things are going well she's she's your
type like she's everything you have ever
wanted kind of thing mm-hmm
slim thick Asian had a bit of room to
win he's a Jew she's Asians and nice
perky tits
click cost flat stomach everything nice
long hair curly even with a bit of a
twang of an accent she can throw down as
well Jesus can throw doubt she can cook
she know everything you are you seen her
Instagram she's banging she's fire
so you see harass show up t-shirt out
one night you guys get to talking you
guys get to talking you exchanged in it
so he staged instagrams and you get
talking even more afterwards the next
day so you guys are getting closer
getting closer getting closer and she
invites you round obviously you go
around there's there's nothing stopping
you from go around mm-hmm so you guys
are chilling you know trying to Netflix
and chill you know the usual schmooze
you guys do you know you know your money
is do it you get closer you get closer
you get comfortable you give her a hug
you you smell the back of her head come
a mile that's that lavender like
eucalyptus yeah she's smiling but
sunshine it's a nice day windows are
open you know everything's nice month
the mood is right don't like report I'm
just right before my style everything is
everything is flowing mm-hmm and then
she's like I'll be right back at be
right back I'm just gonna get something
to drink
it's what everything be like no no no
she goes she goes and does a thing
you're just chillin chillin chillin
watching TV H comes back in a dressing
gown that's a nice silk number with
matching underwear on and she's like you
ready for this and you just the way
you're looking at me now is the way
you're looking at her yeah she's like
are you ready for this and you're just
there like what obviously you had it
inclination this would happen but you
didn't know it will play out the way
it's playing out calm yeah so you're in
gate you're like you're dazed you're
dazed mmm it's just walking over to slow
she's got heels on as well so she's
about she's about five four three she's
a good high she's thick okay so she's
looking up at you still mmm and when
she's there breathe you guys are
breathing next to each other
you're engulfed in the same air good I
mean attention is up from behind yeah
yeah you grabbed her from behind
[Laughter]
continue I'm saying I've imagined it as
jokes you grab us from behind
uh-huh and she's like she's just
whispers you pulls in closer whispers oh
my god
if you whispers in your ear just the nd
you know do you remember do you know the
gift there's good shake whispering it in
someone's ear and you've got the goose
bumps on a hand and they're just an and
it gives us bug guy so she says that in
your ear she says [ __ ] me obviously you
as a man you just rapidly get undressed
yeah yes it's as if it's happened before
yes I got that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah Bruce Almighty so much it just
man you're addressed mmm cuz she's just
there laying in bed waiting for you
playing with the [ __ ] oh Jesus Oh God
yeah and then you're getting - again -
again - it just you've got a dummy say
put the Dom on you slide just the helmet
in hmm I just says no stop I made a
mistake I've got a boyfriend I've made a
mistake
are you saying no not you say no no no
that's a scenario that's a real-life
scenario I know [ __ ] cuz he said no he's
no Tommy are you saying no it hang on
though she said wait they were just we
can do since she said so she said nah I
did stop yeah as a mistake this is a
mistake I'm sorry okay so let me read
the room lol when she saying
so is she saying is she saying max is
she saying stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop like what am i doing is she come to
her senses or if she still she's still
wet wet she's still feeling obviously
she's still feeling I can't go from one
true but if she like if she like
obviously she's still feeling it yes she
like no no no no no I made a mistake
I'll call boyfriend a mistake I don't
want to do this or she like she's that
one she's doing but it's because the
helmets in she's feeling it your throat
she's throbbing it's wet your lips and
your lips in her neck which isn't ah
she's holding you she's her legs are
wrapped around you but she's telling you
to stop she's pushy you're pushing in
but she's pulling away but her legs
telling you to stop I'm gone where I
don't want to do this stop let's just
say I don't want to do this is just you
just say oh what boyfriend's stop no I
don't want to do this stop watch but
everything is engulfed her legs are
wrapped around you oh no you literally
asking me I'm gonna rape someone or not
that's physically what you're asking I'm
asking you that I was getting used up
that's what this don't put wasn't
someone off because wow what a
predicament I would have to stop I would
have to but film you've been doing this
we're doing it now I know [ __ ]
well I guess I have to start wouldn't I
that's the night that's a nightmare yes
that's a logistical nightmare is a
nightmare
I've never speak to her good Oh never
could never I can never speak very good
thing is we say that but we definitely
would babe you change your mind oh my
god what I [ __ ] nightmare what are
you doing so same scenario everything to
say I would probably if he says like
right legs wrapped around helmets in I
should like no no stop I don't want to
do to stop what I wouldn't do this I
think I'll stop and I'll look here I'll
stay in the same position well look here
but I don't ask her are you sure
hmm cuz like we're already here kind of
thing like are you sure you sure you
don't want this and if she continually
says no I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure I
don't want this and I try and pull away
well I'll be like okay and I'd like just
try and pull away mm-hmm if a legs still
wrapped around me when I'm trying to
pull away yep I will stay there and be
like are you sure are you sure because I
feel like if I'm like yeah
I'm not prying your legs apart if your
legs are wrapped around me
we're here to pie we're here to get off
me there if you don't want to do get off
me
that's probably goes to show that's a
perfect example like there's such a bike
there such a tight rope in terms of like
consent these nails fine line there and
a fine line between what's consent and
what's not yeah because everyone's been
in a million different scenarios in
which someone the guy or the girl or
anyone has been like stop we should be
doing this and then but you just like
it's not youíre pin no one but like in
some circles they say you are yeah but
you they're not in this scenario because
there's so many different things but was
it as obviously said this before words
I'm the only language yeah the word
speaks
yeah body language speaks spam so how
can you tell me like your legs are
wrapped around me your ass naked you're
wearing lingerie firm you put your water
for me we're in your house we invite me
back here like you have like you said
[ __ ] you literally said [ __ ] me we're
naked I'm inside you your legs are
wrapped round yeah yeah hands around my
neck I'm back mm-hm like I'm smelling
your chamomile here
yeah that's saying let's do it more than
you saying stop stop stop stop
like it's a minefield I don't [ __ ]
know I don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] Camry
if I could off-camera fam I don't know
it's a tough one brother obviously I'm
saying no obviously my stance is no it's
not happening
but [ __ ] it's easier said than a song
once you've once just feel those sweet
walls
is so much to be fair I've got Dom on
I'll probably stop anyway the
sensitivity goes with it but if it was
wrong with the DA mom stopped I've just
clubbed with a Dom I'm not stopping Dom
I don't wanna do it fine either way
leave the [ __ ] do I I don't know why you
put me put this [ __ ] thing on anyway
but what if it was raw raw you can feel
the juices I'm changing disgusting you
can feel the juices just tricking it
down you Oh God
that's wet we're found that's wet wet
good god I don't know after that is a
minefield
that's a mindful of sweet walls month
boy that's that's a scary scenario from
mrs. garrison oh yeah I'm pretty sure it
happens there's been people that have
gone to court and people have had like
charges put against them for rape mmm
just because nowadays this is not this
is gone past night so this is not even
saying no anymore this is just being
drunk and say oh I wasn't in my right
state of mind to be making these kind of
decisions so they've taken the guide to
court for rape for rape Wow
because you even though the guy throws
consensual rawa there was a case in
America completely consensual the girl
even texts her friend that nice end I'm
going back to what's-his-face is how
stuff [ __ ] they've been like sexting all
day and [ __ ] they went to a party God
drunk she takes that friendzone going
back home my man and to his yeah and
there were both drunk they [ __ ] she
comes out a later date like I don't know
it's not suing him but like taking him
to court saying you rape you raped me
and he thought what the [ __ ] he talking
about and then she said I was drunk I
wasn't in my right stat mind I was like
so was i I was drunk why am i the rapist
yeah but boy this said apparently
there's certain states and [ __ ] like
that were they're saying now that if
you're under the influence of our
oh you're not in a well enough state to
consent big man yes you are yes you are
yes you are I mean all sorts so I I can
consent to all sort of drug and I you're
aware of it right I know when I'm drunk
everyone does I know I'm doing when I'm
drunk everyone does if you're blind
drunk that you won't be able to stand up
and you don't [ __ ] someone that you
desperately don't want to [ __ ] just
because you're drunk exactly like come
on bro that's but yeah the the point one
make year the the lines of consent on
what's not consent these days are thin
as [ __ ]
man around here signing disclaimers like
I can say just get him right thanks bro
down easy is this a world it's a weird
world that we live in bro it's a weird
[ __ ] one that we live in I don't like
it I don't like it one bit do you think
guys can get raped by girls good
question
obviously the axe yes they can do it but
do you feel like a guy we consider it as
rape I don't necessarily think about the
rape aspect of it but I think a guy can
be blackmailed into doing it I think
it's not obviously rape but you're never
gonna rape a guy for when he has to get
hard for two you have to overpower him
yeah and whatever but I think a guy
could definitely be blackmailed into
[ __ ] somewhere they don't want to
[ __ ] in like a I think like obviously
did power dynamics yeah there's
definitely guys that have [ __ ] their
bosses yeah didn't want to [ __ ] him
again yeah but then they're too afraid
to turn to lock off the thing because
they're of their job and self at that
and even women that might be like
brother you best you best keep on
[ __ ] me and especially when talking
about special when you're talking about
like side pieces when you've got a
sidepiece and you're trying to cut it
off you're trying to cut it off as he's
like brough your life ruined if you
don't keep laying that pipe if you don't
keep [ __ ] me I will ruin your [ __ ]
life so I do think men can be
blackmailed i manipulated to do things
that that to have sex when they don't
want to have sex just to some lol I
think that kind of I don't think
anyone's get raped and what do you think
something yeah same I don't I Jenni
don't think he's liking your rapes like
you said you have to get the after get a
guy hard and if I'm not getting hardest
it's not happening for anyone you're
just gonna straddle me for no reason
it's true so it's just like it's that's
very pointless [ __ ] I'm try to think of
us a no manipulation scenario blackmail
scenario so let's say for example let's
say you've got a missus you have you had
your being your missus well about and I
say five years mm-hmm but every every
six months you have to work abroad for a
week for example okay and every six
months you go abroad let's say you go to
somewhere like let's say you go
somewhere in Spain for example and you
go with a colleague from work so the
first time you guys go this for like a
week
okay but that time you go you you don't
even see her in any light like you just
think she's a colleague bla bla and
that's that you go and then come back
mm-hmm you speak to your woman in Vienna
say uh it was it was cool it was good to
see her outside of work just a different
atmosphere different scenario yeah six
months down the line what after that the
first six months the six months that
you're back up work in the UK you guys
start to get closer okay obviously in
six months time again you're going
abroad together yeah do you guys get to
talk and get to talk and get to talk and
get to know a bit more you get to know a
bit more hmm and then you realize like
she's got similar traits to you like the
certs some things you like she [ __ ]
likes as well mmm so for example let's
say anime she's got a few tattoos I
don't know she listens to the podcast
like what do use these little attributes
that you enjoy she enjoys mmm but you
only find that out in increments you
don't find out all in one day okay six
months again later you guys go on
holiday but what she's wearing this time
it's completely different what she was
writing the first time sounds like the
fundamentals of an affair famine that's
all you're talking about
huzza you look about enough fair
but she's not nothing's happened or
nothing happening yeah but you can tell
she fancies you it's one of them ones
where you've never fancy there before
yeah because the more time you spend
with them you're starting to fancier hmm
francy francy I'm sorry too fancy fancy
her
just like too lost over her you think
about her when you're at home cut oh no
yeah that's really similar actually
zooming in you see her in a different
light so to sit like I said the second
time you go with Spain she's looking
banging this is going on her she went
nice little outfits she's hit the gym in
the few six in the six months that she's
been in the UK before she went abroad oh
boy
so you guys you know you get a little
bit closer you're going for like work
lunches and work dinners abroad
yeah let's get to know each other a bit
more hmm you come back for the second
time and she keeps rolling ah the last
time was fine I can't wait for the next
one and you're like yes same it was cool
right there you see her at work again so
a year is gone by the year that's gone
by okay and then it starts to build up a
bit more at work she starts to bring you
like little treats to work every time
you guys go to work together what kind
of trees we told you not to bring you
like she brings you a monster she brings
you cookies she brings in treats she
brings you like anime bobbleheads oh so
you guys are so gay oh wow talk about
tattoo she wants to get okay so your
advice for your program yeah
then she brings in she gets a bit more
personal says like oh I've been my
boyfriend for a year now I'm not really
feeling it and she starts to delve into
like the things that are wrong to her
chest nothing [ __ ] chestnut he starts
to say things like I've been with him
for a year now but I love him but I
don't have that vibe anymore like I feel
like I'm not really connecting me his
you know the things that I enjoy the
things I like to do he's somewhat
against there just doesn't really give a
[ __ ] about me I don't feel like he cares
for ya yeah and I feel like he asked you
like I'm am I wrong if I want to leave
him or and then you know you go back and
form you've known her for a year and you
just want the best of her because you
think she's a cool person you didn't
let's say for example hypothetically you
give it a right saying what you know
what do what's best for you yeah
your happiness is all that [ __ ]
potentially much yeah long story short
lonely hot before the third time you
guys go away mmm
she's left him okay so she's single now
yep she's singin and so for the third
time now you guys are going away like
your missus is unbeknownst to all of
this like she knows you're obviously
going away but she doesn't how close you
guys again okay cool and it's been a
year and a half now so the third time
you guys go away you guys start
obviously before you guys were getting
close you guys are new in each other and
now you guys start to drink when you're
away I start to drink when you're away
oh boy like [ __ ] drinking get loose
get loose like you both go to like a
Spanish joint that's playing salsa oh
you didn't know she could wine and I
hips are just telling awesome Shakira
truth telling all sorts of truth he
didn't truth and then she takes your
really like you're kind of hesitant
because that's not your scene but you
know I just have fun that were here for
what yeah I feel like cool right and get
us a drink if you don't mind I'm just
gonna wait on the dance have fun okay
you come and get a drink but you look
back and you know in movies where you
see a go dancing on a dance floor and
all you can see is her there's a
spotlight on everyone else around here
doesn't mean any sweat glistening
listening and that's what you see when
like you see that slow motion
sway in glistening her hips are swinging
she's looking at you looking at her yeah
and you get the drinks he's like yeah
yeah you guys sip the drinks and you
guys are dancing [ __ ] the music's
blowing hey slow mo guys are dare look
at mean to each other's eyes yes and
then she's like I don't wait for this
for a year and a half I've wanted you
since the first day I saw you I know
you've gone I know you're engaged I know
you're mad I know you've got a woman or
whatever but you are the reason why you
were the reason why I got up every day
you were the reason why I like Jesus
Christ this and do that like I am
falling for you
I am [ __ ] falling for you and I know
it's wrong I know it's wrong but please
just one night just please give him one
night of happiness and she's looking at
you in your boat grabs your tool just
please give me one night happiness [ __ ]
just please one you know what's mad oh I
was so into it until she needed me - no
I'm saying which is that saying I'm the
reason you I get up in the morning on
foot stop stop stop stop
she was Catherine zeta-jones a min ago
she was a young thing yeah love me you
love me [ __ ] [ __ ] off
nah to be fair that's a mad one why
doing this to me today
that's manipulation I go on
maybe we [ __ ] go and yeah go on so
she settled that yeah yeah and you're
like no no no no no obviously not
I know been drinking and stuff
understand your predicament
redditor I just can't do it I mean like
okay fair enough and you start to walk
away and if she grabs your hand as you
walk away this is as James and she looks
you in your boat mmm if you don't [ __ ]
me tonight I'm gonna spill all the beans
and when I tell everyone you raped me I
want to tell everyone you [ __ ] raped
me but I did I know people are recited
this this month true I know it's not
true bro but she's manipulating you know
and when I told everyone that every
single time you come out here you [ __ ]
me and tell me to shop not a soul
and who do you think your wife is gonna
believe oh my god Wow
[ __ ] me like you want me or don't [ __ ]
me and I will tell everyone you [ __ ]
me what are you doing what are you doing
Wow what are you doing that's
manipulation wow that is manipulation
laughter man for you
she obviously everyone's great you work
a scene that you guys are getting close
everyone at work knows you guys go
abroad
yeah wife no she knows what colleagues
know everyone knows so her coming back
saying he [ __ ] me every six months
wouldn't be surprised to some people Wow
so what do you do what do you do [ __ ] me
like you want me [ __ ] me like you want
me or I'll tell everyone you [ __ ] me
anyway and she's gonna say I rape her
you're gonna say you had first time
around you had your way with her it's
what a drunk had had your way with her
but if I do for oisin telling no more
nothing sold she's not telling a single
soul and then if six months time we go
again ah that's entrapment she's not
telling the soul and a mother's life she
won't tell anyone
how do I believe her I don't I don't
know it's all right just know that so
this is on blind it's her bond yeah did
you see yeah I know that she's never
children ever do never tell a soul a
soul but if you don't [ __ ] I could go
to jail for rape telling everyone
[ __ ] it's been a year that will make
that whole scenario will make me want my
wife so badly I'll be terrified you know
in you you're vulnerable and you're
terrified you just want your sister you
you don't know what else you can do I
know what you mean [ __ ] Beth then I'm
thinking in my head I'll be thinking I
just want my wife I was my wife but then
I think and then you go to the other
side and it's like if I do [ __ ] her and
then I'll be a horrible [ __ ] you
because I didn't want to be there but
they like but then I'd be hate [ __ ]
ah yeah you know I'm saying yeah cuz
I'll be so angry that she's got me in
this situation that we bang you know
[ __ ] would be buff you know it would be
buff as well yeah we've had Oh up into
this
we had the night of all night night of
all nights and we've been drinking I'm
already loose that is conniving oh Jesus
these women are not these women are
crazy it's a scenario it's not these
women it happens it's happened it's
definitely happened I know it has
I'm not gonna [ __ ] her or not and then
she says b-but then does she say I have
to keep [ __ ] her every six months
mm-hmm Oh God
well you don't find out until after
that's all until after the if you [ __ ]
then you find out afterwards if you
don't [ __ ] Topsy
okay let's say you do [ __ ] then you
find out afterwards now you know what
I'm this one I'm not [ __ ] that I would
need exactly what you said about the
support I would need my woman so badly
in that situation when I feel like I'm
in trouble
yeah and then she's threatening she's
threatening a family she's threatening
my family and I might lose my family I'm
losing my job losing everything for this
[ __ ] yeah nah yeah now I'm [ __ ] her
why would I [ __ ] you brother yeah I have
to our remote women there then and there
on the dance floor no I'll tell all the
tales then are there on the dance floor
I was saying we were out we were having
drinks in this bit Tommy tower [ __ ] this
shower she's gonna tell you everything
yeah babe like I'm not doing it I'm not
doing it yeah yeah I don't think yeah
I'm not doing it
[ __ ] her [ __ ] Candice [ __ ] her brother I
thought it was Clarisse oh yeah Clarisse
bye Clarice bro the kiss but [ __ ] that's
a scenario scenario from in my right
state of mind I'm saying there's one
thing in the actual scenario when I'm
drunk we're loose loose with this
South's are about everyone in the thing
is hot he is she grabbed my dick I don't
know that's a different kettle of fish
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me like you want
I don't know I don't know I probably are
not [ __ ] doing it that's what you
want to hear yeah do it do it I'll
[ __ ] do it course I would and weak
[ __ ] me like you want me yes okay
a million times yes fine let's do am I
the [ __ ] thousand times yes oh this
is yuck
right am I the [ __ ] for asking
someone to turn off the video while
breastfeeding their baby on a zoom call
I want to say yes but like finish what's
the for work we have morning conference
calls these don't require video even if
you're talking one of our co-workers has
a baby and she breastfeeds her baby
we're on the video cool obviously babies
need to be fed but she doesn't mute her
mic or turn off the video you can read
the my phone we don't see the full boob
but she doesn't cover up I also in
private message to start off her video
during the zoom call and she was livid I
didn't ask publicly I asked privately
she told me I was rude to talk and no
video on and she has the right to feed
her baby right this is you know why I
find this one interesting because thingy
breastfeeding is a tough one like I I
feel like right I'm gonna I'm gonna jump
on just on this one is a controversial
topic but for this specific scenario I'm
gonna say he's not the [ __ ]
yeah because granted I don't like when
people use how do I explain it when
people pretend to not be self-aware just
because of the morality of something if
something is morally right yeah they
think that the owner has
they should do it no matter what yeah
yeah they should there should be no
leeway there should be no workaround
yeah I'm saying they can and they will
do I'm doing I can Anna will my
desert-like breastfeed is natural is
beautiful my baby needs to be fed like
I'll have to do it yeah i deserted
everyone can [ __ ] off yeah when it's
like babes you are responsible adult
yeah you can understand you can have at
least one shred of empathy and
understand that this is a business call
yeah and you're teased out on the
business call yeah and I can hear him
sucking breath your mic is still on I
can hear I can hear it just if you need
to breastfeed your baby on the call yeah
you probably don't need to do it on the
call but for one because it's the same
time every day you can work it around
but if you have to do on the call
blanket same but no blanket over to my
man here well meet you Michael yeah turn
the [ __ ] video off yeah it's route I
told them no no it's not just I'm
breastfeeding my baby I'll turn the
video off until he's done and then I'm
like that's such no one's saying don't
breastfeed your baby yeah like this is a
business cause oh yeah like that and
what that that would annoy me so I don't
like breastfeeding is definitely one of
those niche topics that you ever bring
up yeah if you bring up to anyone yeah
they're just like [ __ ] you but isn't
there there's no wiggle room here [ __ ]
off
like breastfeeding is the most natural
beautiful thing in the world [ __ ] off
yeah I'm gonna say he's not the [ __ ]
um I might have to agree with you I
understand the aspect like you said
breastfeeding is a natural thing it
should be done obviously
babies need breast babies need to be
breastfed and but again read the room
kind of thing she could have like for
example she would never go into work
with her baby and breastfeed her baby
exactly so why do it at home she's
playing a Dom fan yeah she's not playing
Dom because if she's having a Work
Conference at home she's technically
working from home so technically she's
working yeah if she wouldn't do at work
why don't why you doing obviously
understandable you're in home you're at
home your kid is there but over so if
you want to uh need
do it by all means switch off the camera
or by all means
maybe opt out of it and say oh I need to
do on my child for a second I will come
back yeah or one of it like there are
options around it because there's so
many workarounds she can do to prevent
that from happening then so much more
than other ones because oh yeah we have
to all we can say is can you not do it
yeah he gets offended by there's so much
she can do for us not to say that yeah
exactly
turn up the call she could mute the chat
bro rested later she can cover a tee
there's so much she's got options minor
inconveniences yeah what she chose to
she's just using today because she's
stubborn ignorance yeah she's like no
because it's breastfeeding and she
thinks [ __ ] it now
now [ __ ] this so she I feel like she's
the [ __ ] I think she's the [ __ ] as
well I'd nurse a controversial topic and
I'm actually interested to see what the
comments say about that one yeah but I
have [ __ ] her [ __ ] her she's now she's
the [ __ ] and I feel like she because
he the fact that he asked her privately
as well like not to name do it on the
group investor privately I'm sure you
asked her politely as well yeah yeah he
did the right thing when I said she was
livid relax relax
I would love to have that argument with
her well yeah your titties out put your
tea away
just put your titty away it's annoying
but like people don't have example like
even eating even us eating on a
conference call with rude
yeah I've caught us so rude get my titty
out and squeezing out milking so we used
mouths no need um rapidly wrap